there's a life with more freedom for
everyone if they choose to take it but a
lack of belief a lack of motivation a
lack of confidence
a lack of self-worth are preventing
people from doing that if i could give
people the tools to just start that
journey of feeling like they have more
of that then they can start to break
away from this blueprint because
ultimately i think it's letting a lot of
people down
james bloody smith in the building how
are you doing man
i'm very well thank you thank you very
much for having me on i think this has
been quite
long overdue very very very long time
coming
yes so the internet the internet is
waiting on tenterhooks to hear what
we've got to say today
so just to clarify you're not a life
coach
and you also didn't write a diet book
so who are you then i'm still trying to
figure that out myself mate
i like i i felt like i was uh someone
that didn't belong to the fitness
industry
but i was in it uh and then i i
certainly don't want to belong to the
life coach industry but i still want to
venture into it i feel like i'm uh
almost like a lost lost sheep amongst
everyone else
like uh getting into fitness i had such
passion for it but
i'm sure you'll appreciate this i
[ __ ] hated most the people
that i was with and what i didn't want
to do was recreate any of their work in
the slightest and
funnily enough the name for that first
book came i was pissed
with my publishers at hawks more and
you go hawk small for like a nice lunch
in london it's like 5 30 p.m we're doing
shots at the table still with the last
people in the restaurant
and someone's like well what are we
gonna call it because it's not a diet
book
and i was like smashed i was like that's
what we're gonna call it
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] great that mate
three more tequilas please yeah that was
pretty much it and it was kind of like a
nuanced title because
everyone in the fitness industry brings
out their own like [ __ ] diet book or
their system or
whatever it was and i wanted people
straight from the off to think are not
another
flipping personal trainer releasing
another stupid book about broccoli
and burpees and what pained me was there
are people in the fitness industry
that i raised my eyebrows when i read
their books and i was like
their books perfectly right they did
talk about the calorie deficit they did
talk about this
but then the book was [ __ ] boring and
i was like
and i'm not gonna name any names and i
was like how can i do this
how can i kind of come in with enough
anecdotes
information and not try and
talk about broccoli the big thing that
i've realized
upon doing this podcast and speaking to
people like multiple multiple new york
times bestsellers and
and the guys that are the the top
writers in the world
understand that context is important to
deliver a key point
it's the same reason why when you're
scrolling through instagram
you see an inspirational quote which
might be the
condensation of an entire life's work
from one of the smartest people on the
planet
just synthesized into a single sentence
but why doesn't it change your life
because it's in the wrong context it's
like booty picture booty picture dog
photo funny cat video
inspirational quote booty picture booty
you know you're not in the right frame
of mind there's no context to it
so i think that you need to have that
framing around the message that then
actually delivers
what people want and that improves
retention which improves compliance
which actually means it becomes
effective
yeah 100 i mean even tim ferriss on 50
50 with some of his work and others
in the four-hour work week the way he
butts up his points and uses stories
anecdotes travel uh you know all of
these things and then brings you to a
salient point and you're like wow you've
almost been like warmed up like foreplay
and then that point when you read it is
is so much better because you're you're
enthralled in it rather than
you know if he was just open the first
chapter and go the opposite of happiness
is boredom you blah [ __ ] off your
american cliche you know
so you're 100 correct um and
it's almost probably having a physical
book at first
i didn't appreciate that you've got
someone's full attention whereas
social media is it's like it's like
chatting up a bird while
someone else started chatting about five
minutes before and they've not finished
talking
that is a good analogy so talk us
through this new book what's going on
so um the the interesting thing that i
found from the first book was
when i met people on the tour and i
traveled uh no one was
no one would sit with me and go [ __ ]
homemade that the way you broke down if
it fits your macros changed my life
no one was really like mate the thermic
effect of protein was [ __ ] exciting
the the things that like really uh made
people excited they were like james
i've realized the sunk cost fallacy is
affecting me
i realized after reading your book that
i've owned i'm only with my boyfriend
because of how long i've already been
with him not because i want to be with
him
and there was one girl in particular and
she was like
i've just broken up my boyfriend i was
like when she was like yesterday i was
like how long been with him she's like
eight years
and i was like holy [ __ ] like uh
i was like at the time i was like i'm
sorry she was like no no don't be sorry
don't be sorry
and the feeling i got from that was it
wasn't the first time this has happened
because i actually did this when i was a
pt
when i was on the gym floor and someone
would come in they'd vent about their
boyfriend
i'm like why don't you just break up
with him oh we've been together four
years
you know and i was practically doing it
back then that's how it found its way
into the book
but to me it was it was those
conversations i had with people that
really resonated the most and then
when i stripped it back i realized that
the things that people liked from the
first book
wasn't fitness stuff so i was like i
might have to do this again without the
fitness jargon
just as well it's not a diet book but it
should have been even
less of a diet book would have would
have maybe hit even harder
but then i still think it would have
been a perfect companion for someone
starting that journey because
i'm sure you're well aware that when
you're
trying to get people to start a new
chapter or begin a new identity they do
need to strip away
often a lot of relationships and you
know i'm sure you probably
run a lot of people the wrong way when
becoming more successful
and you you know we were friends but
this person's going to slow me down
and arming people kind of the knowledge
to do that is
is one thing i suppose the second book
uh not a life coach gave me i don't want
to be this guru
i don't want to be there like you know
hey guys you can accomplish whatever you
put your mind to but
i want to step in and be like right
there's a there's an interesting part in
the book where i talk about dating
and i say to people we live in a world
where we don't
chat each other up anymore because we're
[ __ ] petrified we're petrified of
engaging with people because of how
social media has changed us
a dm is now the way you can be
chivalrous
and you know instead of going hey i
think you're beautiful can i have your
number we'd be down like
what's your insta babe and we've
completely deconstructed this whole
uh you know approach to dating
and i personally see around me a huge
dropout rate
with first dates based primarily around
the fact there's a lot of anxiety from
both parties
but the anxiety is shed catfishing
is getting worse both sides through
people not portraying
a real identity of themselves from
dating apps we've got face tuning we've
got angles we've got adobe lightroom
[ __ ] pulling five years off of you
you know
and suddenly because of this people are
becoming more and more apprehensive to
meet people
and they're worried about so many
factors so even in even in one part of
the book i was like here's a different
approach
don't go for drinks or dinner on a first
date ask someone if you can walk them
from their office to the tube
why don't you take the dog out for a
walk why don't you grab a coffee why
don't we deconstruct this kind of
notion in society that we need to go
balls in on a first date because
we've all been on a date with a person
in front of us we're one drinking and we
go [ __ ] i'm gonna have to get smashed
i'm gonna have to get smashed to endure
this and i was like
there's one part of the book where i was
like why don't we just do something
shorter sweeter
you know saying someone trying to get an
ice cream oh you train at the gym just
a quarter mile from me why don't we have
a protein shake together or something
because then you can deconstruct that
anxiety for that first proper date
just in shortly meeting someone and
that's just a very small strategy to
to help someone with their life and
that's not tony robbins [ __ ] that's just
me going hey
this is something i've started doing why
didn't you try it too
and my friends around me are doing it
and i was like this is so valuable
and just changing the way that we
approach things to improve their success
rate is supposedly
what the book's all about and that's
that's just one of the bits like have
you ever
found yourself doing that absolutely
yeah i had a conversation with amanda
cuda
who is a um female
coach in america dating so big into
sobriety which
i am i dip in and out of myself and her
number one idea for a date is a walking
dead
like she has a so it's you know you've
stumbled upon something
that's like that so i've got a question
here that was why should anyone listen
to life advice from you but you've
already answered it and it's the same
reason as to why i
think people resonate with my content
and and perhaps yours as well
is that if you live enough life
and reflect on it and then iterate
forward and allow an evolution of ideas
to survive
the ones that you're left with
inevitably end up being all right
and by the time that you've hit 30 35
40. you've got a bit of an idea of
what's going on
like under the age of 25 you you are
completely clueless like even the most
actualized transcendent individual
under the age of 25 years old is
essentially just like a
a child stumbling through the world
desperately trying to work out what
works
but after sufficient failures and
successes you start to see common themes
right
and i i sort of like to try and get a
bit of an insight as to
what it is that you or why it is that
you think that you've been able to sort
of get these insights are you
particularly reflective do you tend to
try and uh look for these common themes
throughout stuff
where's this come from i think that um
the part of your brain that really
analyzes certain areas of your life
in my brain certainly very active so uh
it's very easy for people to go
why are you giving me relationship
advice you've not been in any meaningful
relationship that i've seen
and i'm like okay but have you ever seen
me stay in a relationship i didn't want
to be in
you know and my friends say to me they
go fair play smiths they're like
as soon as you realize a relationship's
not right you get out and
i think that that comes back to being
very appreciative of time
and then when it comes to business over
the last few years
i've learned a lot of business lessons
i've learned in essence
life is all about protecting like a
little bubble that you have around you
of energy
and also i'm very big into how my soul
feels
about certain things and it sounds quite
a hippy thing but
the dating thing the business thing
everything revolves around to what's
going to make my soul happy
and me meeting someone for a very formal
date with drinks
i feel a bit suffocated i'm like what if
i don't like this person what if i don't
like the energy they're giving off
so by improvising that tactic to
meet that person for a swim in the
cereal and ice cream it makes
me feel better about having to go see
someone so
it's like a tactic that's kind of
brought into play and i have these
tactics all around my life
you know um and you know even
even like when you're [ __ ] programmed
picking the time of day to have a wank
i mean you've got to get that at the
right time go have that at the right
time
you've got to fit that in before you're
wrong well then you just [ __ ] you you
ruin
you ruin your you don't want to do it
for a training session
right because then you go into a
training session you feel lethargic
right you do it just for a nap you're
gonna you know you're gonna go under
pretty quick you only need to set your
podcast timer to eight minutes after one
of those
and i know it sounds crass or whatever
it is but like there's
i see so many people tripping themselves
up i suppose this is a good way to
answer your question
it to me it's obvious where people trip
themselves up but they don't see it
and people probably think both of us are
very motivated
but we're probably not we just probably
don't trip ourselves up as much as the
normal person
the key in life isn't being clever it's
avoiding stupidity that's a
shame parishism from farnam street and
it's totally correct
when people hear you as someone who
does multiple solo ig lives sometimes in
a day
and that takes to the normal person a
huge amount of confidence and overcoming
of anxiety and all this sort of
sorts of stuff but even that is just a
craft that you've learned
and the fact that you're able to
identify well actually
in order for me to feel a little bit
more comfortable on a first date
so that i am unconstrained and can free
flow and meet this person
i choose to do something which allows me
to feel that way whereas someone might
just
say oh james has got bottomless pit of
confidence
and endless amounts of charisma and all
this stuff so if it's
good enough for you it's good enough for
everybody else as well
so what are some of the most common
mistakes
that you think people make when
designing their lives
so there's there's quite a few first of
all i think that
everyone's kind of following this
blueprint to life which someone else has
designed
and from generation to generation i
think it's quite dangerous that we take
the blueprint from our parents because
they lived in a very different life to
us
and when people start at school they go
to school
and then when they finish school they
think that their time of development is
done
people think that school's done
education is done that's a very big flaw
because
the best things i learned in life all
came from after school
getting my teachers to expect me to
[ __ ] enjoy reading of mice and men
for instance
that's the worst [ __ ] book i've ever
read maybe
why the why the [ __ ] is that in school
curriculum you can feel me getting
annoyed about this
there are so many excellent fiction
books as well
give me the hunger games give me
something that is i'm
gonna actually from a start there we
cannot rely on the educative system but
anyway that that's
that's one thing and then suddenly our
our parents can often lead us down the
path of becoming the most [ __ ]
qualified
but really who does that benefit fair
enough there are some people that need
to have qualification be a doctor and be
a nurse
but for a lot of other people they're
doing it just to buy time
but then we hit the 20s and i feel that
no one has ever really taught in life
that if there's something they enjoy
they can do it
and one thing that australia really
helped me understand was
people here are a lot happier doing
their job and you go to a coffee shop
here
and you struggle to understand why
someone who's 23 or 24
can enjoy making a coffee for someone so
well
and the truth is that they love their
life their job is just a part of it
when i'm in the uk i see a lot of people
doing jobs they don't enjoy
and in australia that person who's
making that coffee probably clocks off
at 4pm goes for a surf takes their dog
for a walk
meets up with their friends and and does
whatever whereas in the uk the
blueprint's a bit stronger to get
into the nine to five to aim for that
six-figure salary and this is actually
the path that i was put
on and no one ever stopped me or
questioned me i put on a suit to go to
work for like four years and i [ __ ]
hated every second of it
but in my head i was like how am i going
to buy a house how am i going to support
family
how am i going to you know earn enough
money so i can then go to rugby training
in the evening
and the biggest mistake i feel is that
we'll put on this trajectory not once
would
anyone ever stop me and say do you enjoy
what you're doing because
if you enjoy what you're doing you don't
need to be motivated you don't need land
to get out of bed
and i feel so many people just follow
the [ __ ] tracks of
go to uni do your best get a 2-1 tell
everyone you got first
go find it you know go to a [ __ ]
office job bounce in and out of
unfortunate bad relationships with
people that you don't actually like and
you realize after six weeks but don't
split up until after six months
exactly and then and then you know get
on the bags after work
because you you just need an escape
texting your dealer at 4pm
[ __ ] sake you haven't even had a beer
yet then people are so worried about
their pay slip and then
fiddling their [ __ ] linkedin profile
and changing the months
from 10 months to a year to the point
that they don't even know how their
[ __ ] cv looks because they've lied to
themselves so much
and for what for more money
so that you need more extravagant
holidays to escape your dreary existence
in life
and again this is one of the points i
wanted to make in the book that wealth
is
subjective it can't be quantified just
in a bank account
objectively speaking it can but
subjectively speaking i believe that
someone who's hustling with their own
business making twenty five thousand
pounds a year
is far more wealthy than the recruiter
making a hundred grand
so stressed his dick doesn't work when
he comes home to [ __ ] his misses
and he does more bags week than he does
have wanks you know what i mean and
no one blinks at that and it's going on
all around us
and probably another [ __ ]
deep point is if you look at the biggest
killer
of people before retirement it's suicide
right and people no one's no one's
questioning people's professional lives
no one's the biggest cause of death in
men under the age of 40.
yeah and you know everyone's like that'd
be so good to retire at 45
and live my days go here go there and
i'm like
yeah sweet but fundamentally i think
there's something wrong and no one's no
one's talking about it everyone's just
like brushing it off
and i was like people fundamentally
aren't enjoying their professional life
and they're they're all dreaming about
these big salaries six figures and
retirement
and to me it overlooks the [ __ ] the
the best part
and that fundamental is what i think
people are doing wrong and
saving it all for the end is something
that i can't get on with
i can't and there's a life with more
freedom
for everyone if they choose to take it
but a lack of belief a lack of
motivation a lack of confidence
a lack of self-worth are preventing
people from doing that and
if i could give people the tools to just
start that journey of
feeling like they have more of that then
they can start to break away from this
blueprint because ultimately i think
it's letting a lot of people down
but the thing is it didn't let our
parents down it you know
my dad worked in the same business for
50 years started at the bottom made it
to the top and he's a very happy guy and
he's actually happily retired
but i don't think that generation is is
comparable to ours
i agree i agree i had um
andrew scott if i've got his name wrong
i'm going to feel embarrassed andrew
scott
who rosini recently wrote a new long
life which is a book talking about
the economics of the fact that everyone
each generation lives eight years longer
than the generation before
so you versus your great grandparents
you're actually going to live for
another generation on top of them
which means even just from a temporal
duration perspective
using the blueprint that came before
isn't going to work and then when you
think
particularly about the changes that
people my age and your age have seen you
know if you were born
a millennial if you were born early late
80s early 90s
you've seen such a huge paradigm shift
from what your parents experienced to
your
your life and that means that all of the
things all the lessons that our
parents taught us like bless their
hearts like it was
great and it was the best that they
could give us but really like [ __ ]
rules of the game have changed now mate
like it's gravity boots and upside down
basketball and you know what i mean like
it's everyone's flying around in space
and there's you know there's dick pics
and all this sort of stuff
it's exactly that and people are often
comparative to being overweight in their
genes and whatever
and i say to people [ __ ] you i was like
even as a child we would have to walk to
the fish and chip shop to get fish and
chips
now when i order ubereats i don't even
want to go to the door
to get it i buy my house i buy them
something so i don't have to go to the
door when i'm hung over on a sunday
i'm like i'm like boys anyone want to
make flurry yeah i'll get a moment
flurry so when that door knocks i don't
have to go get it
i'm like come on mate i got you mcflurry
go get that but it's funny you say that
about dick pics i had this
conversation with someone the other day
and i was like
if fair enough if you send a dick pic to
someone without consent
that's a bad that's a dickish thing
pardon the pun but
in our lives there are a lot of men
probably listening to this right
that have sent a consensual dick pic and
they worry about it and
i often think that whenever we're
wanking on our laptops we always get
scared for that second that the web
comes on
we all do and anyone listening you say
it you're a liar if not
and some people get really severe
anxiety
and i got a bit of it i was like [ __ ]
out when i released this book
there are probably some videos flurry
flurry of dick pics that are just
strewn around the internet distributed
across the seven continents that could
come back up here
denied he died but then i was like you
know what and this again is another
tactic i use to deconstruct that i'm
like is it really that bad
is it really that bad it's if i was the
only person on the planet send a dick
pic as a teenager when i was drunk to a
girlfriend
then yeah but i wasn't and people need
to get over themselves and again when i
talk about cocaine
everyone's like oh you're talking about
i'm like listen
it's a 5 billion pound industry in
london
where do you think that's going your
doctor you know
you know you're [ __ ] aren't hunky
uncle like everyone you know is doing
this behind
closed doors but no one talks about it
and again psychedelics and
uh people are like james it's really
responsible to talk about psyched alex
i was like no everyone when you talk to
someone
even uh there was a program on netflix
about all the celebrities that came out
and
uh were talking about it i saw i saw
that
and and and you know what that was
liberating for me because
it it i'm not saying that you know drugs
again it's such a broad spectrum of
things some can make your life better
some make life worse
some cure you from illness some don't
and
everyone's so quick to go oh no dick
pics are bad hold on
someone might have sent one somebody
wanted one it was like webcam for porno
everyone's watching porn you know these
are big big industries
and again with like recreational drug
use it's going on
and uh elon musk did a tweet where he
goes
wow five years ago marijuana or maybe
longer was illegal in the states
but cannabis dispensaries remained open
during kovid which means they are now
an essential in the american way of
living
yet people are still in jail serving
their sentences from dealing it
paradigm shift man the world is moving
significantly quicker than the policies
that and enclosing it and
even further than that it's moving so
much quicker than our evolution
which is a huge challenge right because
we are not evolutionarily fit
for the environment that we're in we're
not built for
hyper normal stimuli bings and bongs and
a million [ __ ] messages
dopamine kicks from left right and
center we're not built for the amount of
radiation we take
we're not built we're not even built for
[ __ ] artificial light
like it's supposed to be dark when it
gets dark and light when it gets
light and there's not supposed to be
some [ __ ] ha i've got over there i've
got a brand new very good sleep mask
like so that i can get better sleep
between the hours of like six and
[ __ ] seven on the morning when it's
it's sunny in the uk
like that even that i'm not
evolutionarily fit for that
so people that presume and talk like
with so much [ __ ]
vehement certainty about how how
authentic we are or unauthentic stuff is
talking about how dirty it is to discuss
drugs or how
inappropriate is to discuss dick pics
and stuff like that like it's [ __ ]
bollocks like look at the way that life
manifests itself
now and i think me and you sharing a the
same stance on this which is that
if you lay out the way that the world is
for people
they are free to interpret it however
they want
we have to have faith that people are
sovereign individuals
who are able to make their own [ __ ]
decisions and their
own um they have agency over their own
lives
right like what's the alternative to
pretend that dick pics don't exist
like to pretend that cocaine doesn't
exist to pretend that psychedelics
aren't being used
like how does that help prepare anybody
and it's actually really insulting to
the people that it's talking to it's
basically saying
you are so much of an infant who doesn't
have any agency or control over what you
think or believe
that i'm going to wrap you in cotton
wool and put those little [ __ ] foam
cups that go on the edge of sharp stuff
so that children don't run into it
i'm gonna put all of them around and
then don't worry
uh it will just shuffle you into the
[ __ ] grave
if you see monkeys in the zoo they're
playing with their dicks in front of
dozens of people
you get arrested for these yeah and and
again
that you say there's one thing that i've
probably struggled with from
uh from the only thing i worry about
from a mental health perspective is
this this growing worry of when your
brand and your identity increases your
uh ratio for what you're allowed to get
wrong diminishes
and if someone out there sends a racist
tweet
and there are nobody no one no one does
anything about it and that doesn't make
it fine
but even the fact that like ellen
degeneres
didn't quite get the hashtag right
people were demanding that she donated
money to certain charities off the back
of not getting the hashtag right
and you you kind of worry that you know
a dick pic from a random guy in chat
roulette that's fine
but if it's a major celebrity you know
suddenly
everyone's out to get them everyone but
hold on that's the same
offense between the two and suddenly
people saying something wrong there's
this very it's a very scary time at the
moment in social media where
i've noticed people's posting frequency
since the black square
diminishing massively because people are
petrified of doing something wrong
because the repercussions have never
been worse
have you felt have you felt this kind of
nervousness
absolutely amongst absolute anxiety
yeah ambient anxiety that we're all
swimming through man
like the
i said elon musk was on joe rogan did
you see have you
the second one did you listen to that
yeah yeah and he uses this term and holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] if it's not correct
joe asks him why are you selling all of
your possessions elon waits for
45 seconds in silence and then says
i see it as an attack vector
that's what it is it's an attack vector
your fame now is an attack vector
my platform so i said this yesterday i
launched a patreon yesterday
we've got an academy launching which is
like a different side of the
the modern wisdom universe launching in
a couple of months time and i'm like
feeling more and more anxious now
just low-key ambient anxiety because i'm
like
before when i was doing a thousand plays
a month
it didn't matter but when i'm doing half
a million or a million plays a month
now everything has been ratcheted up
everyone now there's a reason for people
to want to take you down because people
resent success
there's more people to see what you're
doing which means there's more
likelihood of someone
that takes offense seeing the thing that
is going to then erupt into
all of that and once you leverage all of
that together you're like hang on i
actually care about this now
you care about your academy you care
about your clients you care about the
content that you put out you care about
the message and the books that you write
and all of this sort of stuff
and it's your legacy right you don't
want someone
on this increasingly large audience with
this increasing
disposition and reason to attack you to
then take down what is now an
increasingly large operation
like everything all of the [ __ ]
stakes have been raised
it's crazy at the moment there's a
currently uh it's probably happened
about four or five times
there is a organized group of people
that jump on my instagram lives
to try and get me to say words that are
racist by breaking them into names
two part names and then they come on
and say they're trying to catch me out
and obviously stream recording so
they're trying to get me and catch me
out and go
you need to apologize to this person and
i've checked these accounts and they're
real so there's an organized group of
people trying to trick me up
they're [ __ ] crazy they're then
saying to me
oh we've seen that we've seen the tweet
we've seen it it's come up we found the
old tweet
and they were saying they're making
these accusations and on the live i was
like
nah i deleted all my twitter accounts
don't you worry about that i've got
nothing
i buried those and um yeah like and i
was like [ __ ] i was
pathetic and this is the world we live
in at the moment where people would
actually try and out you on something
like that
and then the other day my issue was not
rising to something
and i had a picture up uh from our ifs
uh
events in barcelona and someone went to
the trouble of counting
how many people uh in the picture were
black
and sad face sad face i can't believe
there's only three black people in this
photo
and at first i was like okay and then i
went and i did a
looked at statistics of skin colors
of non-uk citizens that reside in the uk
and from a statistical standpoint it was
actually spot on
the amount so if you say that that was
just broadly uk following that attending
a seminar
in spain for the amount of people in the
crowd for the amount of black people
that was actually perfectly acceptable
yet someone had proactively gone and
tried this is
maybe four weeks after i posted the
picture someone's gone back
they must have scrolled what can i be
offended about what can i be offended
about here we go
there's only but three black people in
this photo i'm really upset
that there's not not more black people
in this photo i was like what's going on
what what world do we live in i don't
know man like
to me i don't i
i don't think like that so when i see
people
acting like that like this whole the the
the
real kind of uh malicious
online atmosphere that's been occurring
recently
i i like i i understand the principles
behind it
but the people that are taking these
sorts of things that are just virtue
signaling and trying to find a problem
with anything
i'm like i i don't even i can't map
their mode of thinking into my existence
it almost feels like i'm watching
like that person it almost feels like
i'm watching a different species or a
different universe or something like
what
is that mirror yeah it's so strange so
let's let's get back to the
the the life thing so you talked about
the the sort of blueprint
this classic of bringing what are some
of the other mistakes
that you think people make when it comes
to life design
so um i would say
relationships is a big one which i
touched on there before
um a lot of people are in
almost like relationships that they're
more platonic they almost
go away from sexual and then after a
while they share a mortgage together and
there's so much on the line they've been
together for so long they struggle to
walk away
now this is another thing that conflicts
with kind of
the other blueprint in which we have of
having a family life but
i sometimes think to myself people are
staying together in a miserable
existence
to bring up a family and it's a tough
one because it's like a double-edged
sword when when kids are involved but
you have to question whether or not two
happy entities bringing up one or two
children or whatever would be better
than staying together for the wrong
reason i see that happening
a lot as well as far as professional
life one of my favorite
areas would actually be sport i love
brazilian jiu jitsu
and i think that if you're
in any form of martial art there is this
sense of humility
no matter what you do you turn up to
training black belts brown belts purple
belts blue belts white belts
no matter what your income what your
ethnicity your religion whatever it is
you line up in order for how good a
student you are not on athletic ability
either
because someone could be 30 kilograms
lighter than you squat half of what you
do but if they're two belts above you
you're gonna you know you're not gonna
call them out for a roll and
i feel that a lot of people become lost
on this path of being a student and
when you even playing rugby i never
really got better
playing game on game you're just out
there with the boys
you know getting on the piss on saturday
night you go train and you learn your
line outs
and i feel that what's amazing about jiu
jitsu is
you can set your own rules for success
so i suppose values
i don't want to be the best jujitsu
athlete in the world and i know i'm not
going to be there
but just the process of improving where
i'm at it's what i love
and you know the same with your podcast
the one we're speaking on right now
although you know joe rogan's there
you're not there like
oh how long it's like picking off the
top spot you appreciate it's there
but you're just working on you you're
like who can i get my next guest what
kind of engaging conversation can we
have
and your podcast won't exist more than
one conversation at a time
like in jiu jitsu nothing exists more
than one session at a time
one transition oh that's interesting one
new way to take the back oh that's
interesting
and being a student and only
transitioning in this blinkers
down mentality is one of the most
satisfying things
i've ever experienced in my life and i
feel like a lot of people don't have
that
and when training for physique or going
to the gym to be in shape
fundamentally i see this big flaw that
people don't really enjoy their training
so they don't really enjoy the process
they're stalemating a bit and they're in
this constant
state of battling off do i want to enjoy
the quality of my life and
drink wine and eat crisps or do i want
to be lean and hungry and
you know not feel [ __ ] energized the
whole time
and if people could just find something
whatever it is
taekwondo kickboxing boxing jiu jitsu
something where they can become a
student it can distract you from
all areas of life and again
a big part of the book is to get people
into just trying jiu jitsu just trying
it out
you were the front end of the funnel for
every jiu jitsu uh
gym that's across the world do you know
do you know what it's
it's honestly been such a great place in
my mind to wander
and for me i i don't take my phone near
the mats often
i go out there nothing else exists apart
from the
training and there's a lot of being
humble keep your shoes away from the mat
keep your hygiene high
shake hands with everyone and you know
we were saying before about
a monkey wanking in a zoo and we're in
this world where everyone seems to think
we're perfect
no matter what human you find we're all
kind of apes at heart
and there's a certain amount of times
you can flick someone on the forehead
before this [ __ ] you in the face
right you could be the [ __ ] nicest
person in the world mother teresa you
piss her off you could piss her off
enough she'd [ __ ] twerk in the nose
and i think from a primitive standpoint
humans
have always been combative they've
always wanted to go toe-to-toe
but we live in this society where you're
not allowed to express your emotions
anymore
you're not even allowed to be angry
being angry is a very normal
[ __ ] human emotion and we have these
social and professional hierarchies that
suppress a lot of people's emotions
if your boss is a [ __ ] to you you can't
call him a [ __ ]
and people sit on these emotions all the
time and they suppress them which i
believe amplifies them
but when you go into like a combat sport
or jujitsu gym you have somewhere you
can channel that and you can vent it
and i think that's very healthy and a
lot of people can't understand why the
nice girl from the office loves boxing
or
why uh you know this dude loves jujitsu
or whatever but she seems she seems so
sweet
did you grow up with any brothers no
only child okay do you ever when you're
a kid did you ever need like play fights
yeah right and and play fights for fun
the mom and dad's in the house if he's
yours or someone else's stick their head
round and be like all right there's no
punching
but you know just just don't break
anything right
and we have all these things taken away
from us in these social constructs but
having a play fight with your mate he
puts the cricket on you want to watch
the football
you're there you're like let's go let's
do this let's settle this and looking
back there's some of my favorite
pastimes now i get to experience that as
an adult
and i think there's something hugely
healthy from a mental health perspective
of engaging in combat with other humans
and you never wanted to hurt your friend
but you wanted to make them suffer
and that's almost the whole sport of
jiu-jitsu that is the sport of jiu-jitsu
precisely yeah
and uh i i wish that more people would
do that because it's
it's been when work's tough when i'm
stressed when i've got that and darren
and i are the same
grade we can go out on the mats and
there's no egos there's
there's nothing apart from this game of
human chess
and when i'm working in the mornings i
do a lot of work when my food comes
i shut off my phone i get rid of
whatsapp and i get a youtube video up
and i'll study like a 10-minute youtube
video of jiu-jitsu while i eat my food
and for me it's just nice to dream off
into another state and learn something
and um i think that i couldn't imagine
life without it
that's beautiful man that really really
is i think
you having found something which is a
common architecture outside
of the thing which most people would
presume is your
calling in life being what has now
become james smith
um having that is
what allows you to do everything else
right like it's the foundation that
allows you to pull yourself out of that
for me it's it's podcasting and
learning about myself and the world
around me when you rang on
skype earlier on before i was ready and
the whole all hell broke loose everyone
that's
been facetimed knows this like your two
phones go off and your ipad
and your laptop and it's like all coming
from everywhere and i was like what the
[ __ ] going on
uh and i was listening to ben shapiro
and i'm like full [ __ ] flow listening
to him talking about trump's speech at
mount rushmore over the weekend
i don't really care but at some point on
a podcast over the next two months
i'm gonna get to drop some stat from
that and i'm gonna go
yes [ __ ] nailed it you didn't know
that did you [ __ ]
like that's that's what i want to do
i've got this one here about the hustle
memory so you were talking earlier on
about how you don't want to necessarily
even go to the door the level of
convenience has been hyper-normalized in
modern society to the point where
we don't want to even [ __ ] netflix
the best films on the planet to our ipad
so we don't need to leave bed and then
we
uber our way to the date so that we can
go home to deliver
our food and all the rest of this stuff
but everyone that's listening think
about some of your favorite memories to
do with any project you've been involved
with
it was never when the project was going
super super well and super super easy
the best memories you have from anything
that you do and this will include you
will be the night before you launched
jimsmithacademy.com
and you rushed until five in the morning
and
we nearly didn't make it and the coda
the code all broke down and we got the
dominoes in and oh [ __ ] we did it we did
it look and we
we made it and it went really really
well that is the meaning
that struggle is the meaning the
obstacle is the way
you know like that's that's what that's
how it works and finding something which
is both challenging and worthwhile
me heil check segment heils flow state
right like that
is we are chasing that we are chasing
something that's just at the right
the right distance of our domain of
competence
just hard enough for us to believe that
we can continue to do it but just
like heart so much hard that we want to
do more
there's um uh yeah and it there's i
can't remember who said it where they
said we need to spend 30
of our time with people at the same
level as us 30 of our time with people
above us
and 30 of our time with people below us
and for me that's
30 rolling with white belts where i can
[ __ ] them up and try new stuff
30 of my time with blue belts of equal
ability where i've really got to bring
my a-game
but then 30 of the time with purple
belts where i'm humbled by them
but and and to me that's the perfect
balance and that's like the hierarchy to
life for black belts
with higher black belts but you just a
second ago your excitement
of listening to that podcast reminding
me another part in the book which
i call the invisible game i play
lots of games every day that no one else
knows about
other people are involved in them but
the people involved with them don't even
know that i'm playing it
and i did this throughout my whole
career very early on where
you listening to that podcast you you
probably without knowing it gamified
your life a bit
and i used to love gaming when i was
younger i still play call of duty now
and it's all about waiting for that
right time for those points to be played
and i found myself i even made a list of
all my competitors
when i first started out as a pt and
everything that i did became a process
to
beat them but it wasn't about an ego or
a cock-off because they never knew that
i was doing it
and i really like gamifying certain
parts of my life
so that i can remove myself from them in
the daily actions of it
getting out of bed on time that's 10
points you know like or you know
when you start studying something i bet
sometimes you're there listening to a
podcast
and you're like [ __ ] this is dull i
remember listening to a 57 minute
podcast on caffeine
and it was dull as [ __ ] the guy was the
most boring [ __ ] in the world but i was
like no one else is listening to this
and when someone asks me on a [ __ ]
live
and i can recite this thing about
caffeine holy [ __ ]
that's when i'll i'll pull up when i
drop the adenosine pathway
bomb on everyone they're gonna go
yeah and that's it and i i saw a bit of
myself then when you were doing that
because
to me there are quite dull and dreary
processes in
life probably like trump's [ __ ]
speech but
if you remove yourself from it and think
someone else could be playing this game
and i got to make sure that i get the
high score
it uh it really helps me uh you know
stay on top of things
and that's that's it's not an ego thing
it's just my way of how i approach
things
and um you know that there's no top
score really like like in call of duty
you just keep prestigion
just keep prestiging there's never
you're never going to be the best but
you might as well keep going
it's interesting that creating those
structures
is such an important way to externalize
motivation
i think that's what helps me like i have
man
those invisible games are everywhere
from how long i'm prepared to count down
in a cold shower from
and like if i if i start to [ __ ] out
then i'll add 10 on
like if i think if i think i should
leave i should just leave early then i
add 10 seconds on
and i'm like [ __ ] sake you did it
again you stood there and you're like
this sucks it sucks it sucks it sucks
like wrote a bunch of i've got this
academy thing launching in a few weeks
time
so yesterday i wrote a bunch of
agreements to myself i wrote promises to
myself about
what i would and wouldn't accept like
i'm going to get up at this time
i'm going to make sure i go for a
morning and an evening walk i'm going
just like the little basic structures
so one of the things i wanted to try and
get from you are what
are the principles or the daily
structures
that you try not to compromise on ever
what do you need to do
in your day-to-day life to ensure that
everything else goes well
um so from a business perspective in
business it sounds really basic but my
inbox and my inbox is actually a lot
more open to people than they think
and because it's so open i think it
helps me where if any of my members
need my help they can always come to me
direct and i've always said that
um so i'd love to clear that then my
email marketing campaign
email marketing is one of the biggest
overlooked
areas of business that everyone
overlooks and if i don't write an email
i almost feel dirty i feel like i
haven't accomplished anything
if i'm too hungover and i don't get that
done that's the port more than
that yeah it is big time i know
jim yeah have you sent that [ __ ]
email paul
he's send the email to get appeared
[Laughter]
that's one of my non-negotiables but in
the last year or two
um quite a lot of my daily things don't
revolve around work it's about
having time to myself training learning
something
uh having a bit of down time but uh yeah
as far as like the
the business part of things i suppose in
my mind clearing in boxes
i probably spend about an hour a day in
my social media inboxes which is tough
because i can't read them all but
i like spending time there um and just
having conversations with the right
people i'm very fortunate now that
i've got my business partner i've got my
events manager i've got all these people
and if i talk to them and just have a
conversation with them every day
everything looks after itself
um i'm not actually that organized i've
been very fortunate over kovid where
i haven't set an alarm to wake up in
about three months
and i finally know i still wake up about
six
6 30 but not having an alarm gives me
peace when i go to sleep
that's interesting man that's how
everyone that i've spoken to that knows
what they're talking about to do with
sleep that's their suggestion
just wake up wake up without an alarm
that's what it that's how it should
be the alarm is cutting into your sleep
presumably you want to sleep as much as
you need
not as much as you want like your alarm
should tell you
yeah i got um i got on it a bit of the
weekend and uh
i woke up like really late on monday
yeah it was
yesterday i woke up at 7 45 and i was
like james
you dirty bastard and i got to the cafe
right i got to the cafe
and they were like the girls at the cafe
were like have you gone for a coffee
somewhere before this and i was like no
no
i'm just woken up and there were no
seats because it got too busy i was like
you [ __ ] deserve this james you wait
outside like the dirty [ __ ] stop out
that you are
outside for a table um but yeah i really
like that and
um again the people around me they don't
want to talk to me in the mornings too
much
sleep is actually probably my biggest
non-negotiable
where um first of all i'm really weird
about
sharing a bed with with people um i'm
not sure if this is a lie that i told
women so they'd leave
and that i've actually started to
believe myself um
but sleeps like a big one that
even if i'm on a date i'm like come on
let's meet a bit earlier so i can you
know get back to bed
and they're like you [ __ ] kidding me
like i like every lights out 10 p.m
every night if i can and
prioritizing my sleep has improved my
quality of life massively
i think very few people realize what
life could be like
if they got eight hours of sleep every
night and this pregnancy pillow that the
viewers will be able to see
i first of all just had like a tubular
long pregnancy pillow
uh i think i could have been one of the
first people ever to fly business class
with a full-sized pregnancy pillow
and the airstrike said to me she goes is
that a pregnancy i said yeah she goes
where did you keep it or is that my
backpack and she was like is there
anything else in it i was like no my
whole backpack
was for my passport my headphones my
pregnancy pillow
i slept for about 13 out of 14 hours
from sydney to abu dhabi
and she was at the end she was like fair
play but now i've got one of the c
shaped pregnancy pillows which is better
but this is going to be another kettle
of fish to get
on a flight but you're going to have to
go in
wearing it like a mid 90s rapper
would wear you know like one of the old
like mink coat things
you can just wear it as what do you mean
what do you mean this is just
this is just part of my outfit i've been
thinking about this already because at
some point i'm gonna have to come back
to the uk and i was like
maybe i can go to the lounge and say
excuse me can i keep this here but no
one at an airport is gonna let me leave
a [ __ ] bag in a lounge are they
huge i'd be like it's it's a pillow
relax and then i was like
maybe i could check it in and ask them
to take it to my seat or whatever but
now that i've done it
i cannot fathom the idea of flying
without my own pillow because
what what strikes me is as crazy as
let's say you fly
return to sydney is about 4 000 pounds
which is extortionate amount of money
but i value my sleep that much
i'm not even being a diva the idea of
not sleeping on top of jet lag
now now kills me i would rather i'd
rather have one less whole day to ibiza
and fly laying down
than i would um any other way that's the
price to pay that's how that's the
equivalency there
ibiza yeah how many ubita trips is it i
don't know how much it costs you i wanna
know how many beta trips it is
the funny thing in uh in sydney is three
hundred dollars for
a bag it's about 150 quid if you want a
bag coat so a friend told me wink
and um like we had to get the washing
machine fixed once
how much is it two bags and you're like
two grand no two bags
six hundred dollars all right
yeah i bought i bought nine square
meters of jiu jitsu mats in kovid
and i was like six hundred dollars and
someone would be like oh it's only two
bags
and like it's quite a funny way of doing
it but uh what what's crazy is that
people i
i once said to myself it's like right
i'm gonna take this pregnancy pillow on
a plane
and i think cos the most expensive one
costs 40 pounds so if you weigh it up
against the cost of the flight
even if you left it on the plane and had
it as like a disposable pillow
it's like [ __ ] filler yeah yeah and
obviously i took it home and i've used
it now my mum's like james you've got
pregnancy pillows all around the world
i've got them in sydney i got them in
london
um but like you know four grand on a
flight fine but you get a pillow that's
[ __ ] half the size of a travel pillow
you're supposed to sleep on that for 12
hours no chance so for anyone out there
if you uh if you're gonna stretch your
legs on the plane take your own pillow
game pregnancy
we need to change the name of it so it's
not just for pregnant people
it's just big blood it's big lad pillow
isn't it it's achy shoulders pillow
that's what it is um anyone who so i
played the pregnancy pillow game for a
long time the challenge i had
was and you'll be familiar with this if
you want to change from
side to side often you wake up because
of the complexity of having to pull your
arm out from underneath to then turn to
then slide the other arm in and under
like it's
it's moderately complex i mean it's
complex to do when you're awake let
alone like
when you're asleep so it's a jiu jitsu
move it's called a hip escape
so you've reviewed okay so you're
drilling the hip escape
in the middle of your sleeve right i
mean that's one way that's one way to
maximize your gains
so what i've actually upgraded to now is
a hourglass shaped memory foam pillow
that slots between
your legs right up against the the gooch
like
right right up against the gooch and
that still does the same
as your memory your pregnancy pillow
will do for your legs
and it separates your thighs which
especially for guys like
until you've slept with something
between your legs
like something big bigger than it is now
like something really big that separates
your thighs you do not know what true
comfort is when you go to bed
like it is just it's wonderful it's not
a day that goes by where i think from an
evolutionary perspective what the [ __ ]
were we sleeping on for so many thousand
years
like what were we like what we before
cotton before wool before springs
i'd and you think from like a
biomechanics standpoint
my back hurts laying on the beach how
did how
how how have we gone that wrong like my
hip flexors i'm so [ __ ] lordic
that like i get a swallower back laying
on the beach and then they were human 25
000 years ago
first oven was being made what were they
sleeping on
we need to find out man that's one of
the regular guests on the show yusuf
slept on the floor for three months
neely nearly broke his relationship
apart
because he wouldn't end an experiment of
him sleeping on the floor and his
girlfriend
refused to sleep on the floor quite
rightly like she doesn't have to
be a part of this bizarre experience
so he put a mattress topper on the floor
so like this this much and the reason
for the mattress top was simply so that
when he went into his bedroom people
didn't think it was weird
um and he slept on the floor for three
months and
did but there's there's some fairly good
arguments for it like firmer beds
benefits
posture and all the rest of it but yeah
man i don't know as well there's a
interesting um you'll have seen these
advertised online
uh anxiety blankets
weighted weighted anxiety blankets
you've seen these like
hyper heavy blankets and they've been
advertised everywhere
and it's supposed to afford some sort of
calming effect
but what's a pathway that that's
operating on
because that's not someone thinking i
really want someone heavy to lie
on me so it has to be instantiated from
our evolutionary heritage
that remind me of something like sleep
paralysis where if some people take too
much mdma they feel like someone sat on
their chest and they
look i don't know uh i don't know where
that would come from that's quite an
interesting one
uh i uh funnily enough uh i think it was
brett contreras that goes
you sleep in the same position for eight
hours you don't wake up stuck in it
so shut the [ __ ] up about your like
posture and uh you know like people are
like
oh don't sit like that because you're
going to get you're going to get froze
them hamstrings are going to shorten
he was like [ __ ] off he was like you're
not weak he was like you're not weak
that's why you stood like that
um which i don't i haven't read in the
studies behind it but it's not like we
get out of bed in the morning like i'm
[ __ ] stuck
yeah um i can't move what life lessons
do you wish that james from 10 years ago
knew any big ones
it sounds really reductive but not to
worry about stuff
you know and this is something this is a
bit morbid
it's another topic in the book like
me and my mate we we had this we had a
few too many beers one night and we came
to this agreement where
we said if we ever found out that we're
going to die we had to look at each
other we had to get a room
let's say you're there with your family
friends your loved ones and the doctor
goes you're going to die in a week
we had to say as loud as we could fair
play that was it to everyone's shock
fair [ __ ] play and he said to me if
we don't live our life that
way that we can happily say that when we
find out we're going to die
then we've really got to change the way
we're living and i don't think there are
many people out there that can say fair
play if they were going to find out
they're going to die next week
so i've been making sure the last 10
years i've been living that way where
i've been given a [ __ ] about mortgages
i've been giving a [ __ ] about savings i
don't care about the stock market
i would rather spend my money on a
pretentious dinner with my friends than
i would investigate in stocks because
uh you know this whole saving it for
later mentality that so many people are
caught up about
i don't see the point i'm worrying about
it you know that's
why bring tomorrow's problems to today
and
yeah i'm literally just going through
life just taking it as it comes doing
what i want i don't know what i [ __ ]
want for dinner tonight let alone what i
want to do tomorrow
and everyone's so caught up in the
future and
to be quite honest we don't know what
it's going to hold and the last 10 years
have become a lot more
focused on the present and whenever i
take psychedelics that's the only thing
i think about
and i wish so many people could let go
of the past
because it's happened um
from i i use space facts quite a bit in
in the second book
when we think of our planet going around
the solar system it sounds kind of weird
this is going to be psychedelic talk we
think of all the planets going around
the sun
but we failed to neglect the fact that
the sun is also moving around the milky
way
it takes about eight hundred thousand
years for it to do a full circle
and i was like when something happened
in the past it physically existed
on a spinning ball going around a
spinning ball of fire that went around a
spinning [ __ ] black hole
that point in time in space time we're
not going to revisit that as a planet
ever again
so why are you revisiting it every day
with your thoughts i may have come
across that in the dmt trip but anyway
and people then we get caught up about
the future and we have no idea what's
coming
so why worry about it and you know we
have today's problems still without we
have today's obligations we have today's
uh you know state of mind to look after
just look after that and
even tomorrow is another days today
so for people that are worrying about
stuff just just don't
what are some of the ways that people
can try and instantiate that or what
some of the tactics that you used
that helped you to actually make that
happen cause it's all well and good
someone listening and going oh it sounds
[ __ ] great that mate
like but i am worried about my mortgage
i am worried about my
job i am worried about whether or not
i've got enough money or whether i'm
going to be seeing stuff like that the
worst case scenario for a lot of
what we think is the worst case scenario
it isn't
and an elephant in the room that i found
is when people face adversity which is
what they're worried about
they often do their best and we're
worried about this point in time where
we can't afford to do things we worry
about this time
where our business does go tits up i
worry about the time and i'm sure you do
that everything's gonna [ __ ]
internally combust
but i tell you what should it do that
i'll probably get out of bed that bit
earlier
i'd probably hustle that bit harder and
i'd probably
try harder and everyone can sit back and
ah it's all right for you but everyone's
capable of it no one i'm not come across
anyone that's
you know i don't even think we have
stupid people on the planet we don't i
don't think we come
in different engine sizes you know
people seem to think no they're a 1.2
printer and someone else is a v8
supercharged
we're not we've all got the same [ __ ]
brains in the same [ __ ] heads
and people need to understand that and
you know what
if the worst case scenario comes i'm
sure you'll buck your [ __ ] ideas up
and have a new set of and
have a better attitude on you and yeah
there's no point in fearing that
and you said again obstacle is the way
if things go good great if they go [ __ ]
i'm sure you'll sort out
there's a an interesting concept
everyone that listened to the episode i
did with ollie march on
will know this example is a guy called
andrew tate
do you know who he is okay so he's kind
of like um
if james bond was an evil supervillain
um son of a chess grandmaster world
kickbox champion multi-millionaire
who lives in a a fortress a bat fortress
in
romania driving fast cars uh and like
[ __ ] porn stars like that's that's
his life uh and he's got this concept
where
he um he talks about having faith that
future andrew will sort it
so he spends money very freely
buy a new car doing this and he doesn't
worry about that he says the reason is
because he's like look i i have faith in
my future self
i have faith that the future version of
me will make the money back if
everything went to [ __ ] i have faith
that the future version of me will make
the money back
and i think it comes it kind of loops
around to what you're talking about
there it's
trusting your future self to sort
whatever challenges arise
but for a lot of people if you haven't
built that trust up in yourself why
would you trust your own word
if you keep making promises to
yourselves about i'm going to start a
diet i'm going to stop cheating on my
boyfriend i'm going to do this i'm going
to do that
and you don't do it inevitably you're
not going to have faith
in your word the same as a friend if a
friend kept breaking promises to you
wouldn't have faith in them either
john that's that's exactly what it is
yeah i couldn't put that better into
words and
angitate sounds like a [ __ ] legend
and i had this discussion with during
where um two years ago
three years ago i would have told you
that flying business class was a [ __ ]
waste of money
like what the [ __ ] i said give me that
money when i land i'll go out and spend
it
but first time um i flew i actually
first time i flew
anything apart from economy i flew first
and it was [ __ ] crazy i was like when
do we eat
and she was like excuse me and uh when i
sat there i couldn't afford it i made
i did a i did two seminars back to back
and i thought oh with the money i've
earned from that i'll just buy this
ticket
but i hadn't taken into account tax
costs the fact that i couldn't expense
things i could
my accounts were all [ __ ] so pretty
much i spent five grand on a flight that
i couldn't afford
and from the outside pragmatically
looking at that that was
[ __ ] stupid but i can never explain
to someone the emotions i felt sat in
that seat
first of all i felt like i'd won the
seat even though i spent five thousand
pounds on a one-way ticket
i felt like i'd won it and i couldn't
get rid of this i couldn't shake this
feeling that i didn't belong in that
seat
but then after a while because a long
[ __ ] flight to sydney i was like i
best start [ __ ] enjoying this
so i had some champagne i had some wine
i'm sat there on my own i'm watching a
film
i've only ever flown economy before and
i not even that i got a taste for it i
made a promise to myself that
from this day on i'm going to do
whatever it takes on a daily basis to
ensure that
this isn't the last time i do it and i
got i actually got really emotional on
my first ever first class flight i sat
there
and i literally felt like well enough i
was like this is [ __ ] crazy this is
mad i've got a shower and a plane
and everyone's supposed to know some of
you [ __ ] afford i couldn't afford it
and looking back now i think that making
that leap and doing that [ __ ] stupid
thing and
i actually got a blessing from my dad
when i did it and i went into the
kitchen i was like
i was hoping he'd push back i was like
dad i'm thinking of
spending a [ __ ] stupid amount of
money on a flight and he was like you're
a long time dead son you might as well
[ __ ] enjoy it
and we didn't say it doesn't swear but
um i i went on it and sitting there was
such a wonderful thing and i said this
to darren
i said darren buy that [ __ ] flight
even if you can't afford it because once
you sit in that part of the plane
you will find a way to afford it and you
will hustle harder it'll improve your
self-worth it will enable you to do so
much
and i wish more people did that because
even those people that are worried
saving for a house saving for a mortgage
hey guess what if you rent till you're
40 if you rent till you're 50
if you rent every single day you're on
the planet
not only do not have to worry if the
boiler breaks it's not your problem
you know no one can take that away from
you that you have the freedom to rent
that doesn't make you a failure if you
rent a house with a smile on your face
then [ __ ] hats off to you because
it's it's not something that we need to
get caught up about and i feel that so
many people are wasting
their positive energy on their living
situation or on something trivial or
money they were supposed to save but
like you say the future version of
yourself
is it's going to have your [ __ ] back
and if they don't
remember your parents everywhere yeah
[ __ ] it there's always
there's always a spare room isn't there
um
everyone that's listening has been fined
so far
by virtue of the fact they've made it
here to this very point
with me and james smith coming in your
ears
you have made it you have been fine
like that is reality reflecting to you
that you are a capable competent human
being
yes maybe you've [ __ ] up tons yes
maybe you aren't everything that you
could be yes maybe your potential is
unfulfilled
but you're actually fine aren't you
you're here with the set headphones in
or in the car driving or whatever it
might be
you are okay why would you not presume
that that is going to be the way that
everything continues to scale moving
forward
like you will be fine a situation will
occur a challenge will happen
a tragedy will strike and you'll be fine
you'll deal with it when it happens
cool quotes relating to what you were
talking about there for
materialism it is easier to fulfill your
material
desires than to renounce them it's naval
ravican
and what he means by that is that it's
significantly easier
for you to say i don't need the ferrari
when you just sold a ferrari or i don't
need to live in australia when you've
just left australia
you want to complete these things a lot
of people moving through
an ascetic life where they have
renounced all of their worldly
possessions and so i don't i don't
really care about this or i don't really
care about that
that is a very easy excuse for you to
just not play the game
it's a very easy excuse for you to just
decide i don't want to compete on a
material level
yeah i agree uh completely with that and
again what you're saying there about
people that might have these worries in
life like
if people aren't happy in life i always
like to challenge them on
whether it's because they're trying so
hard to do things they don't actually
need to do
and people need to be very conscious of
what makes them happy and i don't think
people often
ask themselves that question and uh
funnily enough
i was in norway about eight years ago i
was seeing a norwegian girl
and uh there was a guy on a checkout and
he
was a good looking lad i'm gonna check
out in a superstore it's probably like
23 24.
and when i left i said i was mad like he
seemed really happy
doing what i thought was quite an
average job that's a lot more naive at
this point
and the girl's dad said to me some
people have a very complex life or they
just need a simple job
and i never thought of it like that and
i was like [ __ ] do you know what if he
was caught up about what everyone else
was thinking about what he should be
doing
he probably wouldn't be enjoying his day
half as much as he was but he was just
enjoying it
and i never remember like getting
schooled by by a norwegian girl's dad
and i was like [ __ ] i was like so many
people out there if they've got
complexities troubles things going on
with their life
you know they might want to have a
simple job they might want to do simple
things who's to say that you
walking your neighbor's dog can't be the
thing that makes you happy in life
and then people really need to try and
uh connect with that because
it's almost like people are looking to
other people saying oh my friend bought
a rolex i need a rolex to be happy
my friend just did uh two weeks and i be
though i need to go to ibiza to be happy
when really all these values are are
selected by ourselves
absolutely man what question do you wish
people would stop asking you
hmm probably about whether or not i'm
going bald
because i'm not sure myself you're just
in this this hair purgatory where it
could go either way for the rest of your
life
the thing is my mate's been giving me
banter about going bald for about 10
years i've just got a very fine hair
um but you know i'm i'm not even sure
they go you can have a hair transplant i
go do
do you know what probably won't i'll
probably just shave my head if i'm
honest
like and and even then you know this is
this is something that people ask me
questions about we could get a [ __ ]
another hour of this
going bald is normal for a lot of blokes
yeah
it's become the norm to go i get a hair
transplant
no this is pretty [ __ ] normal same
with women and cellulite and again with
wrinkles i've never had a problem with
wrinkles
i'll throw sunny webster under the bus
he had [ __ ] botox this week
he's like 25. [ __ ] the bed i was like
it's [ __ ] normal wrinkles you got a
bit bald whatever it is
it's [ __ ] normal just leave it but
yeah there are people who are going to
hair transplant i don't [ __ ] know
like you had the opportunity to ask me
any point you wanted about
life happiness psychedelics and you
asked about my [ __ ] hair
follicles do you remember when alan
shearer
hadn't committed to the fact that he was
going bald and he was still doing i
think it was match of the day
and he had he had like uh different
districts of hair that was still
existing around his head
and but he hadn't he just hadn't
embraced it and everyone
everyone was screaming at the tv didn't
care about the football anymore just
screaming at the tv
pleading alan shearer to accept the fact
that he was going bald and shave his
head
you don't want to be that guy like don't
cling on to the comb over is [ __ ]
60 years too late now yeah 100 and and
you know what i think
my mum will probably give me the nod if
my mom goes james it's time for you to
let go
then i'll probably let go if your mother
canary in the coal mine for this
nah she just she's straight talking
whenever i bring a girl home my mum
usually just stands and she's like
no she's not the one
[Laughter]
why is beyond her ears honestly man
mothers have just got this they've got
the
third site haven't they the intuition
100
yeah but the reason i'm saying that this
is quite funny actually this is
completely off topic
the reason i'm saying that is so that
women around the world are like are
proved to his mum
a friend of mine uh said to me this week
he goes for some reason i tell girls i
can't come when i'm
getting ahead and i was like what was i
where's this [ __ ] come from
and then we thought about the genius of
it right he's been telling girls that he
can't come from head
so they want to prove him wrong they
want to be the first person to do it
and he's getting all the [ __ ] in the
world because of it
he can and then he pretends every time
that she's
done some like miracle thing ah fanfare
yes the fireworks come off that is that
is beyond that's beyond clever man there
is wisdom hiding in places that you
would never think it
would you appreciate it i just thought
that was funny so when i'm like yeah
you're never getting past my mum
hopefully there's a few female listeners
going
mrs smith watch yourself show you how
[ __ ] virtuous and good of a wife i'm
going to be
uh final question i'll see diren in
ibiza later this week
what drink or drinks should i buy him to
end his world
uh he'll have a gin and tonic although
he's getting a bit funny that he thinks
uh that jin
is the like the most depressing not as
in
depressing it's the one that slows you
down the most doesn't it jin makes you
tired
i believe i'm not sure it's there's that
like wives
tale thing about it's supposed to be for
um
recent spinster divorcee women that are
like crying on a set of steps holding a
bottle of gin i think that's like the
the stereotype
i think it might be bollocks a bit like
how people say tequila is an uppy
drink which it isn't it's [ __ ]
awkward today he'll have
he'll have a gin and tonic probably
something a bit classier like hendrix
but
if you really want to you really want to
get him get him a pink gin
he uh he loves his pink gin now i want
the thing that's going to hurt him
what does he
shots of any kind like you you'd never
see the life escape someone when you put
a shot in front of him
like and he can't even put a card facade
on that he's like
oh thanks he's just like no i'm not
doing this or he'll just block bruv
but yeah and you you have to get svenger
vincent there as well to
uh yeah just disarm my roof oh so i
outsource
the social pressure to sven
good put the drinker there make sure
that maybe get a crowd small crap
probably put it on instagram
oh darren i got you a shot and then
zoom right in on his facial expression
yeah that'll be it
yeah i'll enjoy that he's uh he's
definitely found his skin uh
over his environment over there he's
he's so much happier so you'd be getting
him on a
on a very good day he seems in a good
fat man i think
um having kept abreast as much as i can
of
of stuff you know like whilst still
leading a life uh keeping up to date
with sort of the way that durham's been
i think his mindset of mine
has probably been a little bit similar
during lockdown that we are used to
traveling moving seeing different things
and there's an upper bound to the amount
of satisfaction that you can take from
hustling and just
using lockdown well i keep getting tons
of messages which is
very complimentary from people saying
it's really good to see that you've cap
it like we're doing three episodes of
a week of this podcast like every week
since lockdown started like
great but there's a level that you get
to where you're like [ __ ] i just need
some variety like i need to see a diff
like smell a different thing
you know like hear the sound of the
ocean do anything
and i think for for someone like darren
and myself and you and sunny as well
obviously like used to moving around
when you get that taken away from you
you really do suffer
in in a bizarre way we were fortunate
enough because
living in bondi it's like i've been on
holiday the whole time once we're
allowed outside that was great
but i said to him i have a lot i talked
to him most days and he was in a bit of
a funk and he won't mind me saying this
i said darren you love london because
london is the most sociable city in the
world
but without with with kovid remove that
social aspect you're just in a concrete
jungle with extortionate rent
and you you can't even go prep and sit
down i was like
i would be [ __ ] in a lot of trouble
if i was over there but
yeah he i said to him you just need to
change your environment and you said to
me a few times i was like mate
you and i beta you're in space sun sea
you'll be [ __ ] on to it and again
leaving even being erratic and spending
a lot of money on
some way to live there he will see that
money back through being a better
marketer and a better human and being a
happier person
and uh people often need to invest in
their present like he is now
and the future as we said will look
after itself i love it man
i love it look james it's been a very
very long time coming you are a little
bit like a
like a bird who is really game
like really really dtf but constantly in
and out of relationships
so i just need to keep timing it right
wait for the next
lap oh he's single again right get him
like and then we can just
you know i mean yeah we'll shoot the
[ __ ] again it's the availability bias
uh the book what is it when is it
how is it uh not a life coach it's uh
out later on this year but you can
pre-order it now
there is links in my bios uh on
instagram and on facebook
link will be in the show notes below of
course to james's socials and all the
rest of this stuff
jamessmithacademy.com
yes please jamessmithacademy.com go and
check that out go and check out
not a life coach um i'm excited man i'm
gonna have to get you to newcastle for
the book tour as well
we are we're gonna be stopping through
i'm gonna make sure of it peace lovely
thank you so much for your time dude
[Music]
cheers
you